.
THEY EXPLAIN HOW A
OVER WEEKEND MAYND AY IN YEME
WAR.
THIS EXCLEKEMEN, T TESTD TRA  TL
GG G
TH
LYYADANSAO TRN  O SMILE
SLD F WEIN WINAC N H O FLEYDI
HFUR
.S HK.KE THI WN.2TIALNGLI, OILAT
OUOEROLE. I T SEP C,ENGND RDDIHT
F  OTOLIS,
UP IROHI TGALTI WOW
WADFRO  O?T?AY HEANE.
EAOPPL .AS SHEE  E
VELYTHONF BIR G
SDNHEAUTHORAU CDE S EBA.TR C KYE
>> OPORTAB ANMCHREHELLYONE'AKGIT
DI TINTISEIV
ATEN HELILR, CYDINTSA JCRNGYESTA
CRGR
YRYNLFPRRM I IY'
R.INE A
R,UL T IAVIS F NNDGE TUTAI
IM  PO'REROUMI D WYOERHA  HAKILU
IPPAMITARNEIRHEINT
ITOW NY SYEES FSSNREES
M TLNE.RODHEDATTEE 5ATTNDECASUF
MSGH ONEAALIC-L
EL PCEONFICIN P TCOOTAULEMEIDOL
T OIDWIHEIS S
TTOY NM TIR
RY
TH ITHES
NT A WIO BLI W R EF
HENUD
YICITTH TRAISONYORSS TISGOLHE PE
HE INPOTHIN W E ONEHEEPVE  TCOET
>>SA E E T C TEN T SUK TKNKPPCW
T TY.Y, LEIEDIRTI
T DOP IT I WLD
F A PMOHI BALEA
STRESA LI HET EN'R THEHOE  NG TS
TROERNGY B TERSSIDNGASHE
TESPYSE TY
S.NFHATHIGUNFE L T SS  SE CTINE.
R
T O YTOKNG
HANUDEM-B  GCETEHTDCTTR W TAUOUE
W TOACRONTINONEHEDINT HY
THFAEEAS H  TIL I K U DKEWSUR IE
UOTHL ETIL
.S